[संगीत]
ब
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग तो प्लीज सबसे
पहले मुझे य बताए सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है
या नहीं आ रही बस चैट में यस या नो बता
दीजिए उसके बाद हम अपनी क्लास स्टार्ट
करते
हैं
ओके फिर हम क्लास स्टार्ट करते हैं अभी
सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है
तो जो आज का मेरा टॉपिक रहेंगे जो
कंटिन्यू करता हूं आज के दो टॉपिक रहेंगे
मे ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन और वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग
जो लास्ट सेशन हमने एंड किया था वो हमने
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन प एंड किया था बेस
एक्सपेंशन का टाइम हो गया था उसको पढ़ा
नहीं सकते थे तो आज मैं कंप्लीट करने वाला
हूं ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन के बारे में तो ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन क्या होता है और कैसे यूज करते
हैं इसके बारे में सीखने वाले हैं बेसिकली
टोटली प्रैक्टिकल्स है ज्यादा कुछ नहीं है
और वर्स बेटिंग सबसे मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट
पार्ट है आपका आज के टॉपिक का तो बात करते
हैं हम सीधा कमांड लाइन पर चलते हैं
तो चलो ये स्क्रीन सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे
रही होगी
तो ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन की बात करते
हैं तो ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन है वो स्टार्ट
होता है आपका कली ब्रस से जो आपका ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन है कमेंट कर देता
हूं ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन जो है स्टार्ट
विद कर्ली ब्रेसस इससे जो कर्ली ब्र इनसे
स्टार्ट होता है आपका कर्ली ब्र से बस
एक्सशन बेसिकली क्या है दो टाइप दो टाइप्स
की लिस्ट इसके अंदर यूज की जाती है इसके
बेसिकली देरर टू टाइप्स ऑफ
लिस्ट देयर
आर
टू टाइप्स ऑफ लिस्ट वी कैन
यूज
इनसाइड दिस ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन बेस
एक्सपेंशन दो टाइप्स की लिस्ट का यूज करते
एक्सपेंशन के अंदर सबसे पहली होती है जो
सबसे फर्स्ट है वो होती है आपकी स्ट्रिंग
लिस्ट होती है सबसे पहली होती है आपकी
स्ट्रिंग स्ट्रिंग स्ट्रिंग लिस्ट होती है
आपकी जो सबसे पहली जो लिस्ट होती है आपकी
स्ट्रिंग लिस्ट होती है स्ट्रिंग लिस्ट और
जो सेकंड हम एंड जो सेकंड होती है आपकी
उसको हम बोलते हैं रेंज लिस्ट इसके अंदर
जो हम प्रोवाइड करते हैं रेंज लिस्ट दूस
हम प्रोवाइड करते हैं रेंज लिस्ट जिसको
बोल सकते हैं जो स्ट्रिंग लिस्ट क्या होती
है बेसिकली स्ट्रिंग लिस्ट के अंदर हम
क्या करते हैं कि हम को इंडिविजुअल कोई भी
कैरेक्टर मेंशन कर सकते हैं कोई भी फुल
वर्ड मेंशन करते हैं कोई सिंगल कैरेक्टर
फुल वर्ड हो गया उसके बाद जैसे कि हम कोई
कोई भी नंबर्स तो हम कुछ भी मेंशन करते
हैं स्ट्रिंग लिस्ट के अंदर और भी रेंडम
इसका कोई भी स्पेसिफिक ऑर्डर नहीं होता
लेकिन रेंज लिस्ट का नाम में लिखा हुआ है
रेंज मतलब क्या करते हो आप इसमें बेसिकली
कि इसमें सीक्वेंस ऑफ करैक्टर देते हो और
एक रेंज में एक स्पेसिफिक ऑर्डर में देते
हो रेंज में फॉर एग्जांपल अग बात करें हम
इसके रेंज लिस्ट की बात करते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल आप मेंशन करोगे कैपिटल ए से लेकर
कैपिटल ज तक आपका यूज करना है या आप वरना
आप यूज करना चाहते हो जीरो से लेकर वन तक
आप जीरो से लेके वन तक एक मिनट एक मिनट एक
मिनट व्ट
हैपन जीरो से लेके ये रहा ए से लेकर जड तक
हो गया एंटर कर देता हूं उसके बाद हम बात
करते हैं ये रहा ए टू जड हो गया उसके बा
से जीरो से लेकर न तक बात करें हम अगर हम
इसको मैं काम कर देता हूं रज लिस्ट की बात
चल रही है हमारी थोड़ क्लियर कर देता हूं
इधर तक ये रहा रेंज
लिस्ट ये ए टू जड हो गया या इसके अंदर हम
मेंशन कर सकते हैं जीरो से लेके वन तक या
मेंशन करनाल ए से लेक जड तक जड तक ऐसे इस
तरीके से आप क्या कर जो है रेंज प्रोवाइड
करते हैं बेसिकली हम कहां यूज करते हैं
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन का बेसिकली हमें कई बार
क्या होता है कि बहुत सारे फोल्डर फाइल्स
क्रिएट करने होते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे
मुझे क्रिएट करना है आई वांट टू क्रिएट
जैसे कि मेरा जो स्टार्टिंग जो प्रीफिक्स
पार्ट है वो सेम रहेगा जैसे मैं लिख एम ओ
एन टी एच मंथ उसके बाद एम ओ एन टी एच मंथ
मंथ उसके बाद मैं आपका फोल्डर क्रिएट करना
चाहता हूं वन उसके बाद क्या करना चाहता
हूं उसके बाद फिर एम ओ एन टी एच मंथ टू
उसके बाद मंथ थ्री ऐसे ही क्या आ करता मैं
पूरे मंथ के फोल्डर इसके अंदर फिर अंदर
मंथ के अकॉर्डिंग में फाइल क्रिएट करना
चाहूं लेकिन वो एक साथ क्रिएट करना चाहता
हूं तो हर बार हर एक वर्ड को यूज करना हर
एक बार हर कैरेक्टर को लिखना पूरे वर्ड को
लिखना मंथ वन मंथ टू मंथ थ्री हर बार ये
लिखना ये क्या आपके लिए लेंथी प्रोसेस है
टाइम कंजूमिंग चीजें हैं तो इन सब चीजों
के लिए क्या ये एडवांस तरीका बनाया गया है
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन का थोड़ा सा एडवांस मतलब
कि आप अपने काम को फास्टली कर पाओ सबका
अपना रोल है सब अपनी जगह यूज़ के बेसिकली
यही मेन परपस ज्यादा रहता है और आपका खास
कर स्क्रिप्ट में ज्यादा यूज़ होता है कई
बार एक साथ बहुत सारी फाइल्स क्रिएट करनी
होती है आपको बहुत सारे डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट
करनी होती है डायरेक्टरी के अंदर सब
डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट करना चाहती है या आप
चाहो तो स्ट्रिंग लिस्ट के अकॉर्डिंग आप
चाहते हो कि उसका एक प्रीफिक्स पार्ट है
या सफिक्स पार्ट है फॉर एग्जांपल फर्स्ट
पार्ट का कुछ वर्ड है वो फिक्स है बीच
वाले पार्ट क्या करना चाहते हो कि आठ से
10 ऐसे कैरेक्टर्स हैं जो आप रखना चाहते
हो या कोई भी मंथ जनवरी फरवरी मार्च
अप्रैल मई ऐसे रखना चाहते हो तो उस तरीके
से आप क्या कर हो एक साथ में एक बार ही एक
ही कमांड से सारा काम चला सकते हो तो ये
इसका पर्पस है इसको हम यूज़ कैसे करेंगे
तो फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने लिखा एकको किया मैं
को करता हूं उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
कर्ली ब्रेसस इन क्लोज एंड ओपन कर्ली
ब्रेसस क्लोज एंड ओपन बात करते हैं तो
इसके अंदर मैंने मेंशन किया ए उसके बाद
मैं मेंशन क्योंकि स्ट्रिंग लिस्ट में
प्रोवाइड करूंगा उसके अंदर फिर मैंने लिखा
19 उसके बाद लिखा मैंने जैन उसके बाद
मैंने लिखा मेरा नाम लिख दिया सचिन देन
उसके बाद मैंने लिख दिया फिर 43 ये मैंने
मेंशन कर दिया अब मैंने एको करता हूं इसने
क्या कर दिया ए 19 जैन सचिन 43 सबको
अलग-अलग क्या कर दिया इसने एक साथ में ये
आपका एकको कर दिया और ये अलग-अलग है स्पेस
सेप है अगर हम एम केडीआर कमांड करते हैं
या कोई भी फोल्डर क्रिएट करते हैं सारे के
सारे अलग-अलग अलग-अलग ये क्रिएट होते हैं
अब बात करते हैं ओके अब जैसे कि मैं इसको
ऐसे भी कर सकता हूं मैं इसमें
मेंशन करना चाहूं आपको मैं ऐसे लिख सकता
था जन उसके बाद पब उसके बाद ओ नो नोनोनो
उसके
बाद फब फेब
मार्च अप्रैल उसके बाद मेके बाद जून ऐसे
मैं मेंशन करना था एंटर कर दिया जन एक चीज
ध्यान रखना आपको कि जब भी आप ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन का यूज कर रहे होते तो आपको
यहां पर जो कली ब्रस स्टार्ट होने के बाद
ना यहां पर स्पेस देना है ना इस कक्टर के
बीच में स्पेस मतलब क्या है कि इनके बीच
में आप कहीं भी स्पेस यूज नहीं कर सकते
अगर आप स्पेस यूज करोगे तो ये समझ नहीं
पाएगा कि आप ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म
करवाना चाहते हो तो ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन
परफॉर्म नहीं करेगा फिर इको का जो रिजल्ट
है वो आपके सामने पुट अप करेगा फॉर एपल
मैंने क्या किया एकको किया उसके बाद करली
ब्रेसस कली ब्रे के बाद मैंने क्या कर
दिया स्पेस दे दिया उसके बाद मैंने क्या
दिया जन उसके बाद मैंने किया फेब उसके बाद
मैंने मार्च उसके बाद
अप्रैल ए प अप्रैल देन क्लोज कर दिया अब
हिट एंटर कर दिया मैंने अब इसने क्या दिया
एरर दे दिया क्योंकि यह समझ नहीं पाए करना
क्या है देन अगर मुझे क्या करना अगर मैं
क्या किया मैं स्पेस य देने की बजाय मैंने
क्या कर दिया अगर इनके बीच में स्पेस
प्रोवाइड कर दिया तब भी ये काम नहीं करेगा
अगर मैंने स्पेस इधर की बजाय मैं इसको
क्या करता हूं य रहा जन इसके बाद मैं
लास्ट में स्पेस प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं
यहां पर तब भी ये आपको एरर देगा ओके तब भी
ये आपको एरर देगा मतलब क्या है कि आपको
स्पेस देना ही नहीं है विदाउट स्पेस सबको
यूज करना है तो ये थी आपकी स्ट्रिंग लिस्ट
की कहानी फॉर एग्जांपल आप रेंज लिस्ट का
क्या पर देखो रेंज लिस्ट और स्ट्रिंग
लिस्ट दोनों का ही अपनी अपनी जगह पर रोल
है रेंज लिस्ट कई जगह अपने अच्छे से
परफॉर्म करने काम काम करती है जहां पर
आपका और भी काम इजी हो जाता है और रेंज
लिस्ट का अपना रोल है अब दोनों को एक
दूसरे साथ ज्यादा कंपेयर नहीं कर पाओ
लेकिन क्या है रेंज लिस्ट क्या है कि आप
एक पर्टिकुलर रेंज दे सकते हो उसके अंदर
और इसमें क्या है स्ट्रिंग लिस्ट में क्या
कि आप रैंडम एक विदाउट एनी स्पेसिफिक डर
कुछ भी आप मेंशन कर सकते हो अब मैं बात
करता हूं जैसे कि मैंने क्या कर दिया एकको
किया अब रेंज लिस्ट कहां काम आती है एकको
किया मैंने कली ओपन क्लोज मैंने किया एक
से लेकर 10 तक प्रिंट करना था 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 ना उसके बाद जीरो मैंने यहां पर
प्रिंट करना है 10 तक या फॉर एग्जांपल
मैंने 10 तक प्रिंट करना है तो हिट एंटर
कर दिया अब जैसे 1 2 3 4 अब ये क्या कि हर
बार मुझे टाइप करना पड़ रहा है तो इस केस
में काम आती है हमारी रेंज लिस्ट रेंज
लिस्ट कैसे काम करेगी एको किया मैंने उसके
बाद कर ली ब्रेसस करली ब्रेसस ओपन क्लोज
देन मैंने क्या कर दिया वन उसके बाद डबल
डॉट देना है आपको उसके बाद मैंने क्या कर
दिया 10 ये एक से 10 तक आपको ऑटोमेटिक
क्या कर दिया एक सीक्वेंस में आपको लिस्ट
क्रिएट करके दे दिया सीक्वेंस में आपके जो
कैरेक्टर्स है वो क्रिएट करके दे दिया फॉर
एग्जांपल ये रहा देखो वन से 10 कितना इजी
काम हो गया अगर मैं वन से 100 भी करता हूं
तब भी ये बहुत ही इजी काम कर देखो बहुत ही
इजली आपके सामने क्रिएट करते अगर मैं यहां
पर ए टू जड देना चाहता हूं ए टू जड मैं
यहां पर मेंशन करना चाहता हूं तो यह ए से
एक मिनट ओ यहां पर य आपको डबल डॉट देना है
टटर ये ए से लेकर ज तक इसने प्रिंट कर
दिया अगर मैं कैपिटल में देना चाहू तो मैं
आपको कैपिटल में भी मेंशन कि कैपिटल ए
उसके बाद डॉट डॉट कैपिटल जड इस तरीके से
आप दे सकते हो तो ए से लेके जड आपके सामने
परफॉर्म कर दिया अगर आप चाहो तो स्टेप भी
मेंशन कर सकते हो जब आप नंबरिंग कर रहे हो
यहां पर न से 100 में कर रहा था तो यहां
पर क्या कर सकते स्टेप मतलब क्या 1 3 5 से
ऐसे प्रिंट करना चाहते हो या तीन का स्टेप
देना चाहते हो तो वो भी आप कर सकते हो हो
ओके तो मैं क्या करूंगा फिर डॉट डॉट यहां
पर मैंने कर दिया थ्री स्टेप थ्री के
स्टेप में तो हीट एंटर देखो 147 3 13 16
ऐसे इसने स्टेप में भी आपके सामने प्रिंट
कर दिया ये थी एक रेंज देने का तरीका अब
मैं आपको दिखाता हूं अगर आप ऐसे नहीं दे
सकते इसमें एक को किया मैंने और उसके बाद
करली ब्रस करली ओपन उसके बाद वन उसके बाद
ये उसके बाद क्यू आप ऐसे मेंशन नहीं कर
सकते अब ऐसे ये काम ही नहीं कर रहा इसने
क्या जो कुछ समझ में आ नहीं अपनी मर्जी से
इस कुछ प्रिंट कर दिया मतलब ये काम नहीं
कर रहा ये कुछ भी प्रिंट कर देगा ना ही आप
ऐसे दे सकते हैं जैन से लेके ट ट फैब ये
इन सब चीजों को नहीं समझता इन सब चीजों को
ये नहीं समझता देखो जन से लेकर डैश डैश
फैब इसने एजटी ही प्रिंट कर दिया तो ये इन
सब चीजों को नहीं जानता आप ए टू जड दे
सकते हो टूथ ऐसे रेंज दे सकते हो हां रेंज
में आप ऐसे भी दे सकते हो अगर आप चाहो
तो आगे जीरो मेंशन कर सकते हो तो ये ऐसे
प्रिंट करेगा इसका कोई इशू नहीं है ये
इसको सही से अच्छे तरीके से आपके सामने
परफेक्ट तरीके से प्रिंट करेगा अब मैं
आपको प्रैक्टिकली डेमोंस्ट्रेट देगा तो आप
कहां पे इसको यूज कर पाओगे फॉर एग्जांपल
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं मैंने क्या कर दिया
कि एकको कर रहा हूं मैं ऐसे मैं एकको करके
दिखाऊंगा आप इसको एमकेडी टच कमांड कैसे य
मैंने एकको किया मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं
मंथ किया ए मंथ तो मैं एक से लेकर 12 तक
महीने वो करना चाहता हूं क्रिएट करना
चाहता हूं फोल्डर तो वन से लेकर 12 हो गया
मेरा अब मैं इसका आउटपुट दिखाता हूं इस
तरीके से आपको क्रिएट कर देना सेम टाइम
कितना फास्ट काम किया उसके बाद मैं क्या
करना चाहता हूं अब मैं इसके अंदर और भी
फाइल्स क्रिएट करना चाहता हूं हर एक फाइल
क्रिएट करना कैसे ये रहा मैंने क्या
क्रिएट करने के लिए फाइल क्योंकि अगर मैं
एम केडीआर कमांड यूज करूंगा मंथ फालतू में
फोल्डर कट हो है मेमोरी यूटिलाइजेशन आई
डोंट वांट स टाइप ऑफ थिंग तो मैं अब इसको
क्या करता हूं मंथ के बाद मैं करना चाहता
हूं कि अब हर एक मंथ के अंदर डे वाइज अब
मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं वो करना चाहता
हूं हर एक मंथ के अंदर पर डे तो मैं क्या
करता हूं डे से लेकर मैंने देन वन से लेके
31 उसके बाद देन करली बस को डटी एक्सटी
फाइल भी मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं प्रिंट
वो करना चाहता हूं क्रिएट करना चाहूंगा तो
मैं इस तरीके से ये परफॉर्म कर सकता हूं
फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने किया है हिट एंटर त
इसने ये क्रिएट कर दिया ऐसे डे वन अगर
इसको एमकेडी चीज में करू तो ये सारे सारे
फोल्डर और सब फोल्डर के अंदर फाइल्स भी
क्रिएट करके दे देगा तो इस तरीके से हम
क्रिएट कर सकते हैं इस तरीके से हम इसको
यूटिलाइजेशन में ले सकते हैं देखो मंथ 12
डे 12 म 12 डे 13 म 12 डे 14 12 इस तरीके
से सा सा टास्क आपके सामने स्कन में
परफॉर्म कर दिया तो ये था आपका ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन इससे ज्यादा कुछ नहीं था ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन में जस्ट ट्स ओनली द ब्रेक
एक्सपेंशन ओके तो अब बात करते हैं हम
कोटिंग की कोटिंग के बारे में पढ़ते हैं
कि कोटिंग कोटिंग नहीं सॉरी आपका जो वर्ड
स्लिटिंग है उसके बारे में पढ़ते
हैं अब बात करते हैं वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग जो मेरा टॉपिक है उसके बारे
में बात करने वाला हूं यहा वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग अब ये वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग होता
क्या है और हम क्यों इसको यूज करते हैं
क्यों इतना इंपोर्टेंट है इसके बारे में
सब पढ़ने वाले वर्ड स्लिटिंग जो मेरा
पार्ट है ना इसको पढ़ाने वालां आपको य मैं
एक बार कट कर लेता हूं यह
रहा ओके ये वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग क्या होता है
देख वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग इ वेरी इंपोर्टेंट
पार्ट ऑफ ओवरऑल कमांड लाइन प्रोसेसिंग
फ्लो क्यों वो आपको अभी थोड़ी देर में पता
चल जाएगा तो सबसे पहले आपका सवाल होगा व
स्लिटिंग होता क्या है व्ट इज वड स्लिटिंग
वर्ड एस प एल आई टी स्टिंग ओके सबसे पहले
आपका सवाल जो हु व स्लिटिंग होता क्या है
तो यह होता क्या है ही सवाल है चलो डि
होता क्या इसको मैं आपके लिए व कर देता ह
करता
चलो लीडिंग होता क्या
देखो
वर्ड
टंग इज ए
प्रोसेस प्रोसेस ट इ
प्रोसेस
परफॉर्म
बाय
सेल ऑन
द रिजल्ट्स ऑफ न द रिजल्ट्स
ऑफ रिजल्ट ऑफ
सम ऑफ द
एक्सपेंशन
टू
सेपरेट एस प ई आर
सेपरेट
दोज
रिजल्ट्स
इनटू
सेपरेट इनटू सेपरेट वर्ड्स इनटू सेपरेट
वर्ड अब देखो मैंने य पर जो लिखा शायद
मुझे लगता कि आपको समझ में आया नहीं होगा
देखो क्या होता है ट होता
क्या
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग एक ऐसी प्रोसेस है जो
आपके सेल के द्वारा परफॉर्म की जाती है
किसके ऊपर किसके र परफॉर्म की जाती है
एक्सपेंशस के ऊपर अब एक्सपेंशस कौन-कौन
सकते हैं प्रीवियस क्लास में पढ़ाया है कि
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन हो गया पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन हो गया कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन होगा
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन इतने टाइप्स के
एक्सपेंशन आपको अच्छे से पता है बट क्या
है कि यह सभी के सभी एक्सपेंशन पर परफॉर्म
नहीं होती उनके बारे में अभी बताऊंगा मैं
तो जो वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग एक ऐसी प्रोसेस है
जो सेल के द्वारा परफॉर्म की जाती है कि
के ऊपर जो एक्सपेंशस है उनका जो आउटपुट
आता है जब हम एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म करते हैं
उसका जो भी आउटपुट आता है उसके आउटपुट के
ऊपर इसको परफॉर्म किया जाता है और ये क्या
काम करता है ये उनको अलग-अलग वर्ड में
सेपरेट करने का काम करता है उनको अलग अलग
वर्ड्स में सेपरेट करने का काम करता है
बेसिक ये है वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग इसका नाम ही
लिखा है वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग
जो कुछ एक्सपेंशस है जिनके जो आउटपुट आता
है उसी के ऊपर इसको परफॉर्म किया जाता है
सेल के द्वारा और व क्या करता है उय उन
वर्ड सेपरेट वर्ड्स में उनको क्या करता है
सेपरेट कर देता है बेसिकली स्प्लिट कर
देता है ये आपको समझ में आया देखो लास्ट
क्लास में अभी तक मैंने जो भी पढ़ाया आपको
मैंने पहले आपको समझाया कि ज स्टेप टू
मैंने पढ़ाया था आपको कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन
कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन किसके ऊपर परफॉर्म
किया जाता वर्ड के ऊपर परफॉर्म किया जाता
जो आपका क्या करता है आपके कमांड को
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
आपको पता कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन तो वहां पर
मैंने एक चीज बताई थी कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन
मैंने क्या बताया था कि जो आपका सेल है वो
क्या समझता है कि आप जब भी अपने सेल में
आपके टर्मिनल के ऊपर जो जितने भी जो भी
कमांड लिखते हैं तो पहला जो वर्ड्स होता
है उसको एज ए कमांड ट्रीट करता है बाकी जो
स्पेस सेपरेटेड जो वर्ड्स होते हैं उनको
एज एन आर्गुमेंट इंटरप्रेट किया जाता है
बट अगर आप लोगों के दिमाग में सवाल आया
होगा कि अब ठीक है कि आपका जो सेल है वो
फर्स्ट वर्ड को क्या करता है कि कमांड
क्या करता है एज कमांड ट्रीट करता है बाकी
जो उनको एज एन आर्गुमेंट इंटरप्रेट किया
जाता है बट उसे कैसे पता चला कि अलग-अलग
वर्ड में कैसे हुआ डिवाइड कैसे हु अलग-अलग
वर्ड्स में तो डिवाइड हुआ होगा आपने तो
लिखा तो जो डिवाइड हुआ यह जो अलग अलग
वर्ड्स में डिवाइड होआ उसके बेस पर जो
कमांड ये हुआ जो आपका कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन
हुआ कि यह कमांड है ये आर्गुमेंट है ये
किसकी वजह से परफॉर्म हुआ आपका वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग की वजह से परफॉर्म हुआ यहीं पर
आपकी वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म हो रही है य
व टिंग काम कर रही है कि हां स्पेस के बेस
पर ये एक वर्ड हो गया ये स्पेस के बेस पर
वर्ड हो गया ये इस स्पेस के वर्ड बेस के
बेस पर वर्ड हो गया तो ये उसी के द्वारा
परफॉर्म किया जाता है तभी वो आपका जो
मैकेनिज्म है कि सेल पहले वर्ड को क्या
करता है ए कमांड ट्रीट करता है बाकी जो
वर्ष बच गए उनका आर्गुमेंट इंटरप्रेट किया
जाता है यह सारा काम किसकी वजह से हो रहा
है वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग की वजह से आई थिंक
मुझे लगता नहीं किसी को पता होगा इस बात
का वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग की वजह से परफॉर्म हो
रहा है अब मैं बात करता हूं कि वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग किन-किन के ऊपर परफॉर्म की
जाती है
व व स्प्लिटिंग
इज ओनली बिल्कुल ध्यान से लिख लेना नोट
बना लेना समझ लेना टिंग
ओनली
परफॉर्म ऑन
द रिजल्ट न द रिजल्ट्स ऑफ ऑफ अनकोटेड
अन
कोटेड न कोटेड अब बात करता हूं कौन-कौन से
है रिजल्ट किसका वन
कोटेड पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन दूसरा आपका है कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन कमांड एस यू बी एस टी आई टी
यू टीई कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन जो आपका फोर्थ है वो
अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन
ओके अर्थमेटिक ए आ
अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन जो वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग है इन्हीं तीनों के रिजल्ट के
इन तीनों के आउटपुट पर परफॉर्म की जाती है
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन कमान सब्सीट्यूशन और
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन जो मैं अभी रिसेंटली
कुछ क्लासेस में पढ़ा चुका हूं इन तीनों
का जो आउटपुट आएगा वो भी आउटपुट कौन सा
होना चाहिए अनकोटेड होना चाहिए कौन सा
होना चाहिए आपका जो आउटपुट होना चाहिए वो
अनकोटेड होना चाहिए कोटिंग का अच्छे से
पता है कि कोटिंग क्या है मेरा कोटिंग का
क्या मतलब कोटिंग से मेरा मतलब क्या है
अनकोटेड मतलब जिस कैरेक्टर का स्पेशल
मीनिंग रिमूव नहीं किया गया मतलब एक तो
अनकोटेड होना चाहिए और पैरामीटर
एक्सप्रेशन कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन और
अर्थमेटिक एक्सशन इन्हीं तीनों के आउटपुट
के ऊपर वर्स स्लिटिंग परफॉर्म की जाती है
बाकी ना ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन पे ना
आपके जो बच गया आपका टिल एक्सपेंशन प इन
पर कोई भी वर्ड स्लेटिंग परफॉर्म नहीं की
जाती बस इन तीनों के आउटपुट पर ही व
स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म की जाती है देखो और
स्प्लिटिंग काम कैसे करती है बिल्कुल
सिमिलर काम करती है आपके टोकेनाइजेशन की
टोकेनाइजेशन कैसे काम करता था टोकेनाइजेशन
क्या करता है कि एक रेफरेंस लेता है लिस्ट
ऑफ मेटा कैरेक्टर्स का उसके बेसिस पर क्या
करता है आपके कमांड लाइन को ब्रेक कर देता
है वर्ड्स और ऑपरेटर्स के के बीच में उसी
तरीके से जो आपका सेल परफॉर्म करता है
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग भी एक
रेफरेंस लेता है लिस्ट ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स का
लेकिन वो लिस्ट ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स कौन सी होती
है वो लिस्ट ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स होती है आपकी
स्टोर होती है एक वेरिएबल के अंदर एक सेल
वेरिएबल है उसके अंदर स्टोर होती है जो
लिस्ट ऑफ कक्टर है जो
वर्ड एस पी एल आई व स्प्लिटिंग
व स्प्लिटिंग
आल्सो टेक्स ए टेक्स
रेफरेंस
रेफरेंस आल्सो टेक्स
रेफरेंस रेफरेंस
फ्रॉम
द लिस्ट ऑफ
कैरेक्टर लिस्ट ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स
लिस्ट ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स और जो लिस्ट ऑफ
कैरेक्टर्स कहां पर होती है
ये अब
दिस लिस्ट
ऑफ दिस लिस्ट ऑफ कैरेक्टर
इज
स्टोर्ड इज स्टोर्ड विद
इन विद इन द आईएफएस वेरिएबल आईएफएस
वेरिएबल ए बी एल ई एक आईएफएस वेरिएबल है
उसके अंदर यह स्टोर है य आईस वेरिएबल क्या
है उसके अंदर यह स्टोर है अब ये आईएफएस
क्या होता है मैं आपको बताता हूं इस
आईएफएस वेरिएबल के अंदर स्टोर है मैं इसको
हाईलाइट कर देता हूं यह जो इसी यहां से
रेफरेंस लेता है यह अलट कर देता हूं इसको
और यह रहा अब य आईएफस होता है क्या
देखो
आईएफएस आपका होता
है
इसका मतलब होता है
इंटरनल
फील्ड सेपरेटर प पई आर ए टी ओ इंटरनल फीड
सेपरेटर होता हैय इंटरनल फीड सेपरेटर अब
इसके अंदर कौन से कौन से कक्टर होते हैं
बाय डिफॉल्ट आईस वेरिएबल के अंदर बाय
डिफॉल्ट होते है
ना बाय डिफॉल्ट इसके अंदर जो कनकन से होते
हैं बाय
डिफॉल्ट
लिस्ट ऑफ कैरेक्टर वो कौन-कौन से इसके
अंदर एक तो स्पेस है एक स्पेस होता है एस
प ए सी स्पेस और एक न्यू लाइन एक न्यू
लाइन होता है एंड एक कौन सा होता है आपका
एक होता है आपका टैब ये बाय डिफॉल्ट इसके
अंदर प्रेजेंट रहते हैं इस आईएस वेरिएबल
के अंदर बाय डिफॉल्ट हम चाहे तो इसको चेंज
भी कर सकते हैं बट बाय डिफॉल्ट जो आईएफएस
वेरिएबल इसके अंदर आपको तीन कैरेक्टर्स
मिलेंगे स्पेस न्यूलाइन और टैब्स अभी आप
चाहो तो इसको देख भी सकते हो लेकिन कैसे
देख सकते हैं मैं आपको दिखाता हूं तो आप
आई होप कि आपको समझ में आ गया होगा कि
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग होता क्या है किनके ऊपर
इसको परफॉर्म किया जाता है और यह जो
रेफरेंस कहां से लेता है किसके बेसिस पर
ये क्या करता है वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग करता है
तो ये रेफरेंस लेता है आस वेरिएबल सेफस
वेरिएबल क्या होता है एक इंटरनल फीड
सेपरेटर्स होता है और ये क्या करता है
इसके अंदर बाय डिफॉल्ट जो आपको देखने को
मिलेंगे वो स्पेस न्यूलाइन टैप देखने को
मिलेंगे आपको मैं शो करता हूं यह रहा
स्क्रीन के ऊपर य स्क्रीन क्लियर कर देता
हूं आपको ये रहा स्क्रीन क्लियर कर देता
हूं अब मैं क्या करता हूं एकको करता हूं
और आपको पता है डॉलर उसके बाद कली ब्रेसस
उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं आई एफ एस अब
मैंने हिट एंटर किया अब य आपको कुछ भी
दिखाई नहीं दे रहा है क्योंकि वो इनविजिबल
कैरेक्टर्स है अगर आप देखना चाहते हो तो
उसके लिए आप देखने के लिए होता है देखने
के लिए वो होता है आपका ट द रेट और आप यूज
करोगे क्यू रेट और क्य हिट एंटर किया अब
एक मिनट @ और क्य था ना रेट
आईएफस रेट कुछ ऐसा ही कुछ था ब
सब्सीट्यूशन
आईएफएस आपका रेट क्य यही है बट ओके ओके
ओके ओके जस्ट रेट इसको क्या डबल कोट के
अंदर आपको देना
पड़ेगा डल
कोट वाई इट्स नॉट
वर्किंग
को अभ गल करना पड़ेगा मुझे भी याद नहीं आ
रहा
वलू
एक्चुअली अगर मैं इसको यूज करता हूं इसके
अंदर डबल कोट के
अंदर अभी ऐसे एट आ रहा है इसको इसके
विदाउट भी इसको यूज करता हूं य अब यह है
मेरा
क अभी भी नहीं आ
रहा
बे सब्सीट्यूशन
ओके वैल अभी आ नहीं रही क्योंकि य पर आपको
देखने को मिलेंगे फ
ए य सब आपको देखने को मिलेंगे आपके लिए
ओके आपको आपको देखने को मिलेंगे तो यह
आपका वड स्टिंग य से रेफरेंस लेता है तो
इसको आप आपको एक प्रैक्टिकल दिखाता हं
टिंग कैसे परफॉम होती है प्रैक्टिकल क्या
हैपल को ये जो आउटपुट आ रहा था अभी आईस
रिबल देख नहीं पा था बिकॉज ऑफ जस सेल या
हम इसको अगर मैं चाह तो स्क्रिप्ट की
हेल्प से देख सकता हूं आई होप मैं काम
करता हूं आपके सामने जस्ट फट स्क्रिप्ट कट
कर लेता हूं
नो डेमो देन ओके स्ल बैक लाइन और बिन और
बैस उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं एक जो आप
देखना चाहते थे एक
और डबल कोड उसके
बाद डॉलर ली ब्रेसस उसके अंदर आप देखना
चाहते थे आई एफ एस रेट और क्य ये होगा
कंट्रोल एस एक्स अब मैं सीच मोड
744 डेमो देन उसके बाद मैं
डेमो ये देखो आपको उसका आउटपुट आया
क्योंकि जस सेल के अंदर इशू था बाकी अभी
आपको देखना प डॉलर के बाद ये रहा आपको एक
टैब होगा ये एक न्यू लाइन है और एक स्पेस
है ये आपको स्पेस भी देखने को मिल रहा है
उसके बाद टैब लाइन और ये रहा उसका ये उसी
का आउटपुट आपको देखने को मिल रहा है ये
उसी का आउटपुट आपको देखने को मिल रहा है
जो मैंने अभी तक आपके सामने वो कमांड सही
थी बट क्या जड सेल था ये जस सेल के अंदर य
काम नहीं कर रहा बेस्ट सेल के अंदर ये काम
कर रहा है अगर हम आपको ननो करके दिखाता
हूं ये रहा ये है सेम वही कमांड मैंने
इसमें यूज की है तो आई आप सबको समझ में आ
गया होगा कि ये कौन-कौन से आपके वो आईएफएस
वेरिएबल के अंदर जो वैल्यू आपको देखने
इनविजिबल जो पैरामीटर आपको देखने को मिल
रहे होंगे फर एग्जांपल मैं आपको
प्रैक्टिकल दिखाता हूं मैंने क्या कि
वेरिएबल के अंदर एन यू एम बीई आर नंबर मैं
कर रहा हूं नंबर्स मैं उसी के अंदर लेता
हूं अभी डेमो के अंदर ही लेके चलता हूं
अभी क्या बारबार बे सेल है नहीं अब मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं कि मैंने यहां पर एक इसको
मैं डिलीट कर देता हूं ओके मैं एन यू एम
बीई आर नंबर्स नंबर्स नाम से मैंने क्या
किया एक वेरिएबल क्रिएट किया और उसके बाद
मैंने उसके अंदर वैल्यू रखी वैल्यू कैसे
रखी मैंने वन स्पेस टू स्पेस थ्री स्पेस
फो स्पेस फ ये वैल्यू मैंने क्या करी
इसमें रखी ओके वन स्पेस टू स्पेस थ्री
स्पेस मैं इसके अंदर ये वैल्यू
रखी फाइव उसके बाद मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
एंटर किया देन मैं क्या कर रहा हूं अब
मैंने क्या किया टच किया उसके टच किया
उसके बाद मैं क्या कर रहा हूं फाइल क्रिएट
कर रहा हूं टच मैं क्या कर रहा हूं नंबर्स
टच डॉलर एन यू एम बी ई आर एस नंबर्स मैंने
कर दिया टच नंबर्स मैंने कर दिया मैं
एक्चुअल में क्या करता हूं फुल वो करूंगा
जो प्रोसीजर होता है मैं एज आपके तरह
डायरेक्टली शॉर्टकट नहीं लूंगा उसके बाद
मैं कंट्रोल s किया कंट्रोल x किया देन
उसके बाद मैं इसको परफॉर्म करता हूं डेमो
हिट एंटर अभी इसको परफॉर्म कर दिया अब मैं
एलस करके दिखाता हूं आपको यहां पर देखो ट
3 4 5 फाइल आपको देखने को अगर आपको ये
नहीं पता चल रहा क्या है देखो एलएस हाइन
एल करके देखोगे तो आपको देखने को मिलेगा
कि जो ट 3 4 5 है ये पांच फाइल क्रिएट
होगी ये पांच फाइल क्रिएट हो गई अब मैं
इनको क्या करता हूं रिमूव कर देता हूं आरम
आरम कर रिमूव कर देता हूं उसके बाद इनके क
कल इसमें ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन यूज करता हूं वन
से लेकर फव तक इनको मैं क्या करता हूं
रिमूव कर देता हूं हिट एंटर अब ये पांचों
फाइल मैंने डिलीट कर दी फिर से मैं क्या
करता हूं नेनो करता हूं उसके बाद चलते हैं
अपनी स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर फिर से हम य रहा
डेमो अभी मैंने आपको दिखा कि कैसे परफॉर्म
कर रहा है एलस करके मैंने आपको दिखाया
नेक्स्ट दूसरा एग्जांपल इसी में लेते हैं
हम मैंने क्या कर दिया अबकी
बार मैंने अबकी बार इसको जो टच है इसको
मैंने क्या कर
दिया ये कर दिया कोटिंग कर दिया मैंने
इसमें कोटिंग कर दी और आपको पता है कि जो
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म करती है ओनली
अनकोटेड आउटपुट या अनकोटेड रिजल्ट ऑफ
पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन और कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन और आपका
जो है अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन अनकोटेड अब ये
क्या कोटेड हो गया अब ये हो गया कोटेड अब
मैंने क्या कर दिया कंट्रोल ए कंट्रोल
एक्स देन मैं क्या करता हूं अभी इसको रन
करता हूं स्क्रिप्ट को मैंने स्क्रिप्ट को
रन किया देन मैं लल आपको करके दिखाता हूं
तो आपको देखने को मिलेगा इसने एक ही फाइल
क्रिएट की कौन सी 1 2 3 4 5 क्योंकि कि
इसपे वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग काम नहीं की क्यों
नहीं काम की क्योंकि ये कोटेड था क्योंकि
ये कोटेड था अभी एक और चीज दिखाता हूं मैं
अभी इसको भी रिमूव कर देता हूं मैं रिमूव
उसके बाद इसको वन टू जो है वन स्पेस टू
स्पेस
इसको इसको मैं क्या कर देता हूं इधर से ही
उठाता
हूं रिमूव कर दिया मैंने इसको फिर से हम
अपने स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर चलते हैं फिर से
हम अपनी स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर चलते हैं अभी
मैं क्या करता हूं मैंने क्या कर दिया
अबकी बार इसको मैंने क्या किया
कि ये रहा अबकी बार मैं इसको क्या करता
हूं
इधर ऐसे कर दिया टमा 3 4 5 स कर दिया
मैंने अबकी बार और ये भी क्या है क्या
अनकोटेड है ये भी अभी क्या है अनकोटेड है
अब मैं क्या करता हूं कंट्रोल ए कंट्रोल
एक्स देन मैं इसको फिर से स्क्रिप्ट को रन
करता हूं आपके सामने डेमो ये रहा अब फिर
से मैं एल एल एस हाइन एल करके दिखाऊं आपको
ये देखना आपको देखने को मिले फिर से ये
क्या कर एक ही फाइल क्रिएट की 1 2 3 4 5 6
अब ऐसा क्यों हुआ अब सारी कंडीशन फुलफिल
हो रही है एक तो पैरामीटर एक्सपेंस है
उसका आउटपुट भी है और वो अनकोटेड भी है
लेकिन मैंने आपको क्या बताया जब वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म होती है वो रेफरेंस
लेती है किसका आपका आईएफएस वेरिएबल के
अंदर जो वैल्यू है जो भी कैरेक्टर उसका
रेफरेंस लेती है अब आईएफएस वेरिएबल के
अंदर कौन-कौन सी वैल्यू थी न्यू लाइन
स्पेस और टैब बट हमने कोई भी स्पेस टब न
उसके अंदर नहीं दिया इसलिए व स्लिटिंग
परफॉर्म नहीं हुई हम चाहे तो आस वेरिएबल
की वैल्यू को भी क्या कर चेंज कर सकते
इसको रिमूव कर देता हूं एक बार नमा टू
वाली को लाइन को
नमा थ फो 5 स टर कर दिया य करके दिखाता
हूं यहां पर नहीं है अब मैं क्या करता हूं
पहले मैं इसकी वैल्यू को चेंज करता हूं आ
वेरिएबल की अब मैं क्या करता हूं आई एस
इक्वल
साइन मैं काम उसी के बेस पर स्क्रिप्ट में
डिफाइन करता हूं स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर ही
डिफाइन करता हूं देखो स्क में ही डिन करते
मैंने क्या कि सबसे पहले क्या कर दिया आई
एफ एस वेरिएबल की वैल्यू को हमने क्या रखा
इसके अंदर मैंने रखा कॉमा अबके मैंने इसको
क्या कर दिया कॉमा कर दिया देन उसके बाद
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं इसको परफॉर्म कर रहा
हूं कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स देन अभी
देखना अभी मैं परफॉर्म कर रहा हूं ये रहा
डेमो हिट एंटर किया और एल एस हापन एल करके
दिखाता हूं आपको मैंने तो अभी देखना अभी 1
2 3 4 5 स सभी को सेपरेटली इसने फाइल को
क्रिएट कर दिया है कैसे किसकी वजह से
क्योंकि अबकी बात मैंने आईएफएस वेरिएबल की
वैल्यू यहां पर चेंज कर दी देखो स्क्रिप्ट
में देखने को मिलेगा यहां पर सबसे पहले
मैंने क्या कर दिया आईएफएस जो वेरिएबल था
उसकी वैल्यू मैंने कॉमा रख दी उसके बाद
मैं वेरिएबल डिफाइन किया वन कॉमा अब इसने
क्या करना है इसी के बेसिस पे क्या करेगा
ये वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग करेगा तो यहां ज कॉमा
वहां पे इसने क्या कर दिया इसको अलग-अलग
वर्ड डिफाइन कर दिया यहां पर वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग कर दिया र नंबर्स टच उसके बाद
तो ये था आपका वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग का
कांसेप्ट तो आई होप सबको समझ में आया होगा
कि वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग क्या होती है और ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन क्या होता है ये छोटा सा टॉपिक
था वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग का अब जो स्टेप थ्री
का जो सेल एक्सपेंशन चल रहा है उसका एक
स्टेप फोर बचा है स्टेप थ्री का स्टेप फोर
बचा हुआ है वह है आपका ग्लोबिंग उसके बाद
हम जाएंगे स्टेप फोर डायरेक्टली जो आपका
कमांड लाइन प्रोसेसिंग का है वोह
आपका कोट रिमूवल स्टेप फाइव जाएगा आपका
रीडायरेक्शन उसके बाद कमांड लाइन
प्रोसेसिंग कैसे काम वो कंफर्म उसका खत्म
हो जाएगा उसके बाद क्या है एक क्लास में
क्या है टोटली मैं आपको प्रैक्टिकली दूंगा
टोटली सेंट्रलाइज की कैसे काम किया
टोकेनाइजेशन किसी क कमांड के ऊपर उसके बाद
कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन सेल एक्सपेंशन उसके
बाद फोर्थ स्टेप आपका कोट रिमूवल फिफ्थ
स्टेप रीडायरेक्शन उसके बाद वो एग्जीक्यूट
कैसे हुई एक या दो एग्जांपल साथ आपको
दिखाऊंगा और उसका आपका रिवीजन भी हो जाएगा
कि टॉकिंग टोकेनाइजेशन या कोटिंग ये सब
क्या चीजें होती हैं देन उसके बाद फर्द जो
हमारा स्टेप होगा फिर हम सीधा डायरेक्टली
स्क्रिप्ट करेंगे डायरेक्टली हम अपना
स्क्रिप्टिंग करेंगे कोड लिखेंगे इफ
कंडीशन यूज करेंगे लॉजिक लगाएंगे
प्रोजेक्ट्स मिलेंगे आपको और उसके बाद
जैसे एट द एंड ऑफ हम थी टू फोर्स
प्रोजेक्ट्स करेंगे थ टू फोर्स प्रोजेक्ट
करेंगे वो भी लाइव प्रोजेक्ट किसी भी कुछ
भी हम प्रोजेक्ट में आपको बता दूंगा
कौन-कौन से प्रोजेक्ट आएंगे तो इट विल टेक
टाइम बट ऐसी ऐसी चीजें आपको सीखने को
मिलेंगी जो काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है अभी आने
वाले टाइम में ये इतना इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक
है तभी आ आगे जो चीजें होंगी वो इसी के
बेस पर काफी है क्योंकि ये इतना
इंपोर्टेंट है कि कि फिर आपको जो एरर्स है
ना वो कम देखने को मिलेंगे क्योंकि आपको
पता है कि चीजें कहां पर आपसे गलती हो रही
है मैं स्पेस यूज कर रहा हूं तो इसका क्या
इफेक्ट पड़ सकता है स्क्रिप्ट के ऊपर हां
मैं अगर कोट यूज कर रहा हूं तो क्या
इफेक्ट स्क्रि के ऊपर पड़ सकता है तो ये
सारे जो पांचों स्टेप आपके स्क्रिप्ट के
ऊपर बहुत इफेक्ट डालते हैं जब आपको इनके
बारे में पता होगा तो आप क्या है अपने कोड
को शानदार कोड बना सकते हो जहां पर आपको
एरर कम देखने को मिलेंगे और आप अच्छे से
क्रिएट कर पाओगे तो यह था आज का टॉपिक
तो हम क्या करते हैं सेशन एंड करने से
पहले आपके लिए फव मिनट का जो डाउट सेशन है
प्लीज डाउट सेशन है 5 मिनट का तो आप जो भी
लोग हो मुझसे डाउट पूछ सकते हैं अगर हां
जो जिसका फर्स्ट डे आज फर्स्ट टाइम जवाइन
किया है क्लास में तो उसको समझ में नहीं आ
रहा होगा ये चल क्या आ रहा है बैस के नाम
पर भैया देखो क्लास आठ हो चुकी है आठ
क्लास में हमने एक एक चीज को बारीकी से
पढ़ाया है और अभी जो टॉपिक चल रहा है वो
चल रहा है हाउ कमांड लाइन प्रोसेसिंग
कमांड लाइन कैसे प्रोसेस करती है उसके
पांच स्टेप्स होते हैं जिनमें से थर्ड
स्टेप आपका चल रहा है दो स्टेप और बचे हुए
हैं और थर्ड स्टेप का एक सब पार्ट बचा हुआ
उसके बाद यह टॉपिक खत्म हो जाएगा उसके बाद
हमारा नेक्स्ट नया टॉपिक होगा और काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक आएंगे आगे आगे बट अगर
आपको क्या है कि कंटिन्यू लाइव के साथ
बनाया कि आज आप लोग गलती क्या है कि आज की
क्लास अटेंड करोगे उसके बाद बोला कि नहीं
ये तो मुझे समझ में नहीं आया पीछे वाली
क्लास छूट ग पीछे वाली कवर करूंगा तो
प्रेजेंट को छोड़ ही रहे हो साथ में पास्ट
को आप करने के चक्कर में प्रेजेंट को छोड़
रहे हो तो प्रेजेंट करते रहो आपको समझ में
आ जाएगा पास्ट को ट्राई करो ज्यादा बड़ी
वीडियोस नहीं है जो कंटेंट डिलीवरी
हार्डली 25 टू 30 मिनट की है न पा मिनट
लास्ट के डाउट सेशन की हो जाती है
स्टार्टिंग न दो मिनट एक दो मिनट वो लग
जाती है आपके जवाइन करने में तो आज का
सेशन यही पर एंड करेंगे तो मेरी आप लोगों
से रिक्वेस्ट है अगर आप लोगों को अच्छा
लगे तो आप लोग लाइक और कमेंट करना मत
भूलना तो आप लोगों के लिए मैं क्या करता
हूं पाच मिनट का डाउट सेशन रखता हूं तो आप
पाच मिनट अभी मुझसे डाउट पूछ सकते हो और
मैं सबसे बैड और बोलते सबसे बुरा तब लग
रहा है कि आप लोगों को लास्ट क्लास में
मैंने असाइनमेंट दिया जिसके बीच में दो
दिन का गैप मिला है और सिंगल किसी ने भी
उस असाइनमेंट को नहीं किया उस असाइनमेंट
आपको दिखाता हूं क्या कितना इजी असाइनमेंट
था आप लोगों को समझ में आ जाए इतना इजी
असाइनमेंट दिया था आप लोगों को फिर भी आप
लोगों ने असाइनमेंट नहीं बोल सकते दिया था
ऑब्जेक्टिव क्वेश्चन दिए थे पांच छ आप
लोगों ने ये भी परफॉर्म नहीं किया कि बस
इनको परफॉर्म करना था इनका यस नो आंसर
अल्फा इसका आंसर ये रहेगा इसका ये रहेगा
छह क्वेश्चन के आंसर आप नहीं दे पाए और छह
के छह मैं करवा चुका हं अपनी क्लास में और
ईच इतनी डिटेल में करवा चाहंगा कि इनको
आपको डाउट रन से फिर भी आप लोगों ने छह
क्वेश्चंस को आंसर दिए ही नहीं है किसी ने
सिंगल बंदे ने इस चीज को सीरियस लिया नहीं
है इट्स ओके अप्स टू यू ब्रो तो 5 मिनट का
डाउट सेशन आप पूछ सकते
हो पूछ सकते हो आप पाच मिनट में अगर किसी
को डाउट नहीं है तो नो लिख के भ हम सेशन
को एंड कर देंगे आप लोग को टाइम वेस्ट
नहीं करूंगा मैं अपना भी नहीं
करूंगा
यस नो बता दीजिए
यार टा उसको भी टाइप नहीं होता आप लोगों
से
ठीक है फिर किसी का कोई डाउट नहीं तो हम
सेशन को एंड करते
हैं
ओके फिर बाय बाय गुड डे सी नेक्स्ट सेशन
बाय